Yle Areena.
Ja uusiksi tullee ihan kaikki mennää uudeksi maailmanjärjestyksejä.
Sillä kaikki kyllä voittaa, ihan hirveesti voittaa, kun ihmiset kuoloo vähii,
ja näläkei tuolla, ja korjuttakkei tuolla, ja sähkövirattekin mennää poikki,
mutta kyllä lähetää uusta sähköä, kyllä ei moita, kun kerää aurinkoista vaista sähköä,
ja sillä ellää, ni kyllä sitten pärjää, ja tuulivoimalat antaa kyllä hirveesti sähköä,
ja vaikkä tuuliskaa, se kyllä ei hyrrää aina, ja kaikki menee niin mukavasti, kun tulee uus maailmanjärjestel sytetä,
se vasta muolema pelastuu.
Eipä tarvitse sen kummemmin katsoa rivien väliin, tuon äskeisen puhelun viesti menee kyllä perille,
maailman kehityksessä lähdetty vähän väärään suuntaan, ja ehkä sitten jonkunnäköiselle uu-käännökselle olisi tarvetta.
Se on kansanradio ja Lasse Olkinuoretessa tervehdys.
Risua ja ruusua taas tällä viikolla jaetaan.
Eli, aika tuttuun tapaan edetään, ehkä nyt menneen viikon aikana on tullut poikkeuksellisen paljon vähän pidempiä puheenvuoroja.
Esimerkiksi, Espanjasta löytyy ratkaisu, jos ne kadun varrelle jätetyt koiran tortut harmittavat.
Korjaamattomien pökäleiden lisäksi pahaa mieltä aiheuttaa muun muassa sanojen väärinlausuminen, puoluetuet ja kiittämättömyys.
Ja, vaikka olympialaiset ovat jääneet tuon helmikuuhun, niin niistäkin jäi muutama asia kaivelemaan.
Kansanradio.
No, tämän on kuule kokkolasta vaan, yks vanhus. Ja mä oon tämän nii mieleni pahoittanu, ei tullu kansanradio.
Kylä to on niin veemäinen koko helvetin radio. Että meitä vanhuksia, tyrmikää. Onko tämä enää laillista?
Olympialaisten aikaan oli kansanradio, ei tullut normaalia aikaa, mutta ensisunnuntaina taas tule.
No ei se, paljon kuule hele, totta se on kaks mennyt, kaks kansanradioa ohi. Ja maailman politiika arkipäivää.
Ne on ainoa, tätä mä sunnuntaina kuuntelen. Ja sitten tietysti näitä illalla enää mitää tuukkaa yleisradiosta,
mutta sitten TV:tä, mutta kyllä mun pistää nii vihakseni, että.
Niin, ei, ei, nuo olympialaiset ei sitten ole sinun makuun.
Ei, kuule, minä en olympialaisia katoo ikinä. Mutako silloin, nykänen vielä hyppi tuolani, silloin mä katoin.
Se oli semmoinen, niin kiltinnäköinen poika, että maailma pilas sen.
Koko pojan, nii.
Saikohan se vähän liikaa suosiota liian nuorena?
Sai, sai, niinko tämä toinenkin hyppäjä, mikä sen nimi nyt oli, joka oli tässä nyt hiljattain TV:ssä.
Se pilalle kans, sille työnnettiin rahaa ja autoja ja muuta rihkamaa.
Joo, siinä pitäis olla nuorella, tuollaisessa tilanteessa kyllä ihmisiä ympärillä vähän suojelemassa ja kattomassa perään.
Niin pitäis, joo, kyllä.
Tämmöstä kuule.
Ei, hyvä ku soitit, mutta lohduttaako se ihan vähän, että ens suunnutaan ja palataan normaali?
Kato, mä oon hengissä, mä oon kohta yäksentympinen.
Se on kuule, jokainen päivä kuule, se on armonpäiväs, mä helän.
Yritän pysyä kuule hengissä, ihan sun takijasta.
Ei, mainio juttu. Minä kiitän, ku soitit tänne.
Nonee, kiitos.
Ja, päiväjatkot moi.
Joo, nimi merkki, entinen jääkiekö tuomari.
Oon seurannu ihan innossaan näitä jääkököpelejä, tosi lahdikkaita, näin, mutta hyvän pelin on pilannu nämä NHL tuomari, sovintalassa Kanadaa vastaan.
Täysinkäsittämätön jäähy, Kanadalainen nosti omaa mailansa, ja sitten tuli sitten jäähy, ja hoja 40 sekuntien loppua tuli sitten voittomaali.
Nää oon ihan täysiä pellejä, nämä NHL tuomarit, silloin näkyään show aina päällä, ne ottaa pääroolin.
Jotenkin tuntuu, että tässä on ihan semmoista valtataistelua.
Valtataistelua NHL vastaan, eurooppalaiset tuomarit, että ihmettelen kyllä, että eikö tää eikö muita tuomarita löydy ku amerikkalaisia ja kanadalaisia näihin jääkököpeleihin.
Pilataan, hyvä peli näettä.
Mitä on ollut jäikö tuomarit, no ni täytyy sanoa näettä.
Vaikka ei pitäis haukkua tuomareita, mutta kyllä ne on ollut ihan onnettomia. Hei.
No, Savosta, Trivi. Olis kommentoinut näitä öljimpialaisien selostajien tyyliä, että käy vähän ketutta toi, että selostajat huutaa keskenään kilpaa, ja se, että kannattais vastaa silloin huutaa, kun Suomi saa mitaleita. Kiitos, ei muuta.
Yljä täällä. Ei näe mitkään olympiakisata ole, ku vene ei ole mukana. Nähän on vaan länsimaiden olympiakisata.
Kansanradio.
No, se on Matti, kun täällä langoilla pelaa.
Matti, mitäpä kuuluu tänäsunutan?
Toto, semmoinen kolme sanaa olis kiva osata näitten. Ammattiselostajien minusta.
Kolme sanaa puuttuu heidän sanavarastostaan, kerro.
Se ei puutu, mutta ne muuttuu, muuttuu.
Aa.
Esimies tämmöinen kuin "mitali", niin se on ihan mahdoton sanoa oikein, se on aina "mitali".
Liikaa äliä yritetään tunkea sinne.
On, joo. Minuuttissa on niitä kaks kappaletta, mutta sekuntisanassa on vain.
Sitten on olympia, sana on kauhean vaikee.
Siitä kuulee kyllä hyvin paljon, olympia, olympia, joo.
Nii. Mitä oli sekuntia olympia?
No, sitten tietysti jo näitä tämmöisiä murrekommentaattoreita, kun on niitä hootapannaan musti laittaa sinne ja tänne.
Tenki se vaan tänne korvaa sattuu.
En tiedä, onko korvisodikka?
Nii.
Kai se sinne ei laittaa et pystään olla.
Oikeastaan mä oon kärsinyt hirveästi kahdesta jumalan antamasta lahjasta.
Toin on tämä hyvä kielikorva, jopa minä hyvänä.
Toin on musiikikorva.
Se on ihan mahdoton, kun joku vetää ihan pieleen, niin sekin sattuu.
Sinulla on erinomainen sävelkorva, näin sanot.
Mulla nyt ei oo ihan vielä täydellinen, mutta tossa hyvin lähisuvossa lastenlapsella,
myseelläkin, on se noin niin sanottu absoluuttinen sävelkorva,
joka sitten on pikkuisen parempi vie kuin molla.
Ei, mä en tässä itse niitä halua kehua siinä mieleksessä,
ja kun sanoinkin juuretta, sitten ei oo hyötyä.
Sommasta tapauksela, sitten kun itse soittelee,
ja puhaltelee jotakin trumpetia tai muuta,
niin siinä on hyvänkin mukava, että jonkollista korvaa.
Must, toi on toi, olympia jotenkin, no onnyks se nyt loppuu tässä näin.
Kuutelin vaan niitä nyt jotakin,
ei oo kaikki ihan tyytyväisiä nyt tähän yleen,
mut ei oo kyllä kaikki sitten löytäneet niitä kanaviita, viesijät, eikä.
Esim. areenaa, ku väitetään, et ei näytetä tarpeis jotenkin suomalaisten menestystä,
mutta kyllä se sieltä löytyy, ku haiskelee.
Me sanotaan siis kauan eläkön sanojen oikein lausuminen.
Joo, ja olympia aadi.
Näin me teemme, ja kiitoksit sinne sulle, ja hyvää päiväjatkoa.
Minä toivotaan samaa. Kiitos paljon.
Kiitos, moi.
No, sinne jäi olympialaiset, ainakin lähes kokonaan, varmaan nyt keskustelu,
esimerkiksi tuomarivalinnoista tulee jatkumaan, vielä jonkun tovin.
Mutta urheilullahan on sellainen vaikutus, että joskus se aiheuttaa pitkä kestoistakin jossittelua,
itsessä ainakin huomannut sellaista piirrettä.
Kansanradiossa siirrytään seuraavaksi ostoksille,
tai osa haluaisi mennä, mutta eivät pääse, ja osa käy taas liian ahkeraan.
Meille on tullut seuraavanlainen kirje.
Hyvä kansanradio, paljon on puhuttu,
Temusta, ihmiset tilaa miljoonia paketteja, minäpä kerron omakohtaisen tapauksen, tai tarinan.
Eläkkeellä olemme molemmat pieneläkeläisiä.
Mies, selkäsairas, päivät makoilee, ei jaksa tehdä mitään,
mutta jaksaa tilata temusta, eli sormi liikkuu.
Joka viikko yhä useampi paketti, mukakuulemma tarpeellista.
Velkaa tulee krääsään, voitais käyttää rahat muuhunkin.
Eikä mikään sanominen auta, tällaisesta tulee riitaa.
Loppuu vielä tulee vähän kirosanaa, Temua kohtaan, nimimerkki väsynyt, on laittanut tällaisen viestin meille.
No tääl on kansanradion, iki oma, satu, täti, jälleen, kerran teidän, kaikkien ilona.
Mä olen nyt seurannu näitä huonekalufirman, askon ja sotkan tilannetta, mutta mulla on yks vinkki.
Ja, jos tääl on jotain kuuntelemassa tät kansanradiota, askon työntekijöitä tai johtohenkilöitä, niin sanokaa sille omistajalle, että se ostaa koko firman takaisin, koska Asko on sellainen kulttuurihistoriallisesti, yks Suomen suosituimpia huonekalukauppoja ja tehtaita.
Ja ne on tehny laatu, kaluja, ihmisille, ja mä toivon kaikille, kansanradion kuuntelijoille, oikein kivaa, kevättä, terveisin, kansanradion, ikki oma, satu, täti, hei, hei.
Hei, syni, hoi, kansanradio, olen valmis, juu.
Toi oli, tuota, no, sellainen just, tu, tää huonekalu, asko ja sotka, kun ne mei konkurssiin, että ei oo yhtään ihme, jos mei konkurssiin. Huonekalut on helvetin kalliita.
Ei yksistään askolla ja sotkalla, vaan niitä on vielä kalliimpiankin huonekaluliikkeitä.
Täälläki keskustassa on yks kalishuonekaluliike, siellä on niin hienoa desinkiä, että mä ihmettelin, että mitenkä se oikein pärjää.
Ihmettelin, että miksei kuluttaja suoja lautakunta puututtele siin kiskuri hintoihin.
Kun oo aikoihin eletty, ku no S-marketin, no vainokset, ku se pitää, tää Tanemimäkinen koko ahelelt, tää, miten viikoloppi, ja mitä sä syöt, S-kaupasta.
Ei no se jälkeen käännu S-marketissä, ku tää, ku vootu salako toi, kasko ei oo ihmiset sitä yhtää noterrat.
Kaupaa ei välitä mitää, mitää ne asiakkaat venevät, ku hapa paskaa ja hoveta.
Tää, tää, niitos syytti.
Sinne ihan korkeimmille palleille on suunnattu seuraavat puhelut, niitä ennen yksi kirje, jonka alussa lukee, että olkaa hyvä, ja lukekaa tämä kirje.
Kylä niin ottaa päähän, tuo Orpo. Mielestäni syyttää kansalaisia, kun eivät kuluta. Katsoisi peiliin, niin sieltä näkyy syy, miksi ei kuluteta.
Joka kohdasta leikataan. Pakkohan se on pitää vähän rahaa jemmassa, jos sattuisi pääsemään lääkäriin tarvittaessa. Sekään ei ole halpaa.
Orpo ei anna mitään arvoa tavalliselle kansalle, ei varsinkaan eläkeikään ehtineille, eikä vanhuksille.
Karritas terve, lähettäisin tälle presidentille terveisiä, että hän poistaisi nämä valtion puoluetue, koska jos joku haluaa perustaa puolue, ni kerätkö ne käyttörahot jäsenmaksuilla, ni ku normaali muutkin, kerhot tai vastaavat laitteet.
Se on ihan turhaa valtion maksaa puolueelle puoluetukia, että se on ihan älytön asia, ja nämä rahat pitäisi käyttää taas näin sotepalvelujen korjaamiseen ja parantamiseen.
Tämmönen asia, että valtiohan ei poistaa valtion puoluetukia, mutta presidentti pystyy sen tekemään, että hänelle terveisiä. Toivottavasti hän kuuntelee tai joku välittää viesti. Kiitos, hei.
Politiikan pitää olla yhteisten asioiden hoitoa, kaikkien hyväksi. Nykyiset poliitikot ajaa vain omia etujaan, nostaan palkkojaan ja saavat erilaisia etuja, esimerkiksi kenkärahaa. Tämä on niin väärin ja rikollista, että köyhiltä ja keskituloisilta koko ajan riistetään, päättäjä, käsi sydämelle.
Haluatteko todella tappaa vähäosaiset kurjuuteen ja nälkään? Muutos on tultava. Ministerien ja kansanedustajien palkat pitää alentaa viidelläkymmenellä prosentilla, ja niiltä, joilta on riistetty, pitää hyvittää 50 prosenttia lisää eläkkeisiin ja opiskelijoille sekä köyhille lapsiverheille.
Kansanedustajien määrä pitää alentaa viiteenkymmeneen henkilöön. Näin voimme säästää rahaa koko kansamme tarpeita varten.Päättäjät.Päättäjät myöskin sodan uhkaa lietsoo, tehden ihmisille pelkoa ja epävarmuutta taloudellisen alasaajon lisäksi.
Venäjä ei pidä härnätä, vaan diplomatiakehiin ja kauppasuhteiden luomista, niin todennäköisesti Venäjä ei hyökkää Suomeen.Nyt peilin eteen päättäjät, jos ette ennen ole sitä tehneet.
Paskanen nauru, ku kuulin, että Ville Rydmanista tuli suu sosiaali- ja terveysministeri.Tää niinku sakenee tää soppa vaan koko aja.Tää Suomi on yksi so vitsi nykyään.Ei voi muuta sanoa.
Ja järjestää niin, että niin paljon soppatykkejä, että saa valita hernekeitto, riisipuuro, kalakeitto, tomaattipuuro, tomaattikeitto, hei vaan.
No morjensta.Toivoisin, että joku näistä nuorista päättäjistä miettiessään, miten näitä sairaanhoidon ja vanhusten hoidon kustannuksia, miten näitä voisi pienentää, keksisi vanhain kodin uudelleenkäyttöä.
Kun vanhukset on kaikki siellä samassa talossa, niin miten paljon säästöä tulisi, ja kuinka paljon helpompaa olisi heidän hoitamisensa.
Apu olisi aina läsnä.Ei tarvisi hommaila, näillä hoitajilla autoja, millä ne ajelisivat ympäri maakuntaa, ja jokaisella vanhuksella riittäisi enemmän aikaa ja hoitavia käsiä.
Minua tämä ei tule enää koskemaan, minä olen seitsemänkympinen ukko.Niin nopeasti tässä maassa nää pyöräntä ei pyöräntä, että siinä vaiheessa,
jos minä tarvisin sitä vanhainkotia, niin sitä varmasti ei ole vielä keksittää. Mutta aina he sitä voisi toivoa, ja seuraaville polville parempaa.
Eli meillekin kohdistettu nämä seuraavat viestit.
Vivi haluaa kertoa kaikille pari sanaa aiheesta lapsen tai nuoren turvaruoka.
Joskus syystä tai toisesta lapsella on suuria haasteita syömisessä, jos lapsi ei pysty syömään päiväkodin tai koulun listalla olevaa ruokaa, oppiminen ja jaksaminen on huonoa, siksi on tärkeää, että lapsi syö edes jotain.
Media on nostanut esiin, esimerkiksi turvaruosta, kalapuikot. Mutta turvaruoka voi olla paljon muutakin kuin kalapuikkoja, itse olen hoitanut lasta, jonka turvaruoka oli yksikeitetty peruna ja yksikeitetty porkkana, noita kahta hän söi lounaksi, joka arkipäivä, kolmen vuoden ajan.
Kyse ei ole lapsen nirsoilusta tai vallankäytöstä, hän ei vain pysty. Lähes kaikki haluaisivat syödä, kuten kaveritkin, joukosta erottuminen ei ole heidän tavoite.
Jokainen, joka tuomitsee turvaruuan, voi miettiä omalta kohdaltaan, että millaista olisi ollut kasvuikäisenä paastota, joka arkipäivä yhdeksästä kymmeneen tuntia.
Olisitko silloin jaksanut oppia, leikkiä ja liikkua? Näin meiltä kaikilta kysyy Viivi.
Kansaradiotervehdys.
Jussi Oulusta soittelee huomenta.
Hyvää huomenta, Jussi.
Tummosta asiasta. Soittelee olen 76-vuotias nytten, ja kun olin 15 vuotes, sain mummuta hyvään ohjeen.
Eli ruokaisyvä lopu vasaamattomuuteen.
No nii.
Ja toinen, tämän taivan asian, euron iso raha pienata, pieni raha menettää.
Kedelle tämä viesti on erityisesti suunnattu?
Kaikille kansalaisille.
Ihan kaikille kansalaisille. Minä kiitän paljon, ku soitit tänne.
No ni, kiitos.
Hei.
No hei, jos me suomalaiset ruvettais käyttämään tätä kivijalkakauppaa, niin sanottua, ja pieniä vaatekauppoja, ja ostamaan niistä näitä tuotteita.
Ja unohtaisimme jokskuks aikaa, joksikin aikaa, nämä nettikaupat tuolta, niin oisko sillä vaikutusta tähän suomalaiseen talouteen täällä meillä, et saatais vähän tämmöstä yrittelijäisyyttä ja tuotantoa tänne Suomeen. Tässä vaan tämmönen juttu. Kiitos, hei.
No nyt pitäis ottaa tota kansallinen liikunta, liikuntajuttu, sen takii, että kohtaa jo palomiehii ollenkaa, koska kaikki nuoret on nii huonokuntoisia.
Eli tällainen kansallinen liikunta, liikuntajuttu, ni tällä saatais näitä ihmisiä liikkumaan.
Se on ihan sama, mitä ne tekee, vaikka kävelis, että kouluu pitää saada enemmän niitä liikuntatunteja.
Olin tossa 2020 koulussani, siellä oli valinnaisaineenani liikunta. Se on kyllä aivan väärin.
Eli, toivottavasti, nyt joku, kansanedustaja kuuntelee, tai sen apulainen, ja laittaa tän kuntoa, mut ei mulla mitään muuta.
No tuhotero täältä roihiksista.
Halkää kansanranion kuuntelijat, välittäkö siitä, että vähän hiuksia särkee toi?
Hyvä elämä on, elämä on, se on hienoa.
Eritasoista hämmästystä, ihmettelyä, kysymysmerkkejä herättävät nämä seuraavien puheluiden aiheet.
Samalla tavalla on kysymysmerkkejä täynnä tämä yksi meille saapunutu viesti, joka alkaa, että mitä ihmettä.
Lääkäri soittaa tuloksista, ja siitä peritään yhtä suuri maksu kuin käynnistä vastaan otolla.
Kyllä tulokset potilaalle tulee tiedottaa ilman lisämaksua.
Tämä on todella asian kuulumatonta rahastusta.
Potilas on maksanut tutkimukset, ja hänelle tulee kertoa tulokset ilman erillistä maksua.
Kuulemaan tutkimustulokseni, kasvoista kasvoihin.
Nyt on paljon ollut tätä puhetta tästä, ku tuodaan sitä mafian, sitä jätettä sieltä Italiasta tänne Suomeen poltettavaksi.
Sehän on, nykylainsäädännön mukaan, sehän on uusiutuva luonnon vara.
Täällä, yks.
Yli 80-vuotias.
Mummeli.
Vuosikymmeniä ihmitely yhtä asiaa, joka koskee koko Suomea.
Miks miehet kaliuutuu, eikä naiset.
Osaako kuka kertoo?
Kiitos.
Hyvää päivää, tai iltaa, tai miten vaan.
Siiä on, niinku, järki mukana, ja se on tervettä, ja turvesta järjestäne maahan.
Ruotsi, se turveki uusiutuu, mut ei Suomessa, se oo eri laji varmaan.
Ei.
Täällä, yks.
Yli 80-vuotias.
Mummeli.
Vuosikymmeniä ihmitely yhtä asiaa, joka koskee koko Suomea.
Miks miehet kaliuutuu, eikä naiset.
Osaako kuka kertoo?
Kiitos.
Hyvää päivää, tai iltaa, tai miten vaan.
Soittelen täältä Ankelniemeltä.
Katselin, kuuntelin Aastodioo, ja ihmettelin kovin, kun siellä oli semmoinen nuori haastattelija,
meidän entistä presidenttiä, Saulininistöä, ja sinuutteli.
Minust se oli aikamoinen etikettivirhe.
Ja, jos on tarkoitus sinuutella, ni ensinnäkin siihen tietysti pitää saada lupaa.
Ja toisaalta sit taas jotkut, jotka ovat saaneet luvat, ovat esittelyssä jo kertoneet,
että minulla on lupa sinuutella, tai me sinuuttelemme toisiamme.
Ja, tää meni vähän niinku pieleen, tää koko hänen haastattelus,
siitä tuli enemmän seurattu sitä, nithän ei virheitäs, kun itse niinistyä.
Ei muuta, heippa.
No, se on Jonantuuma, karjalampoiko täällä terve?
Tuli tossa mieleen, että millähän saais tulla Petterden ja Riikalle niinko ynnäpäätä pikkisen lisee,
kun ne valittaa tästä, että suomalaiset eivät kuluta enää.
Ni osaa vaikka ne laskee tätä, että minkä verran sillä on vaikutusta,
kun on toimeentulotukea, aika monenkohalia työttömyyskorvauksia,
pienentänne puolittanut, leikannut ja tehnyt vaikka mitä,
että sehän on monen miljardin säästöt, jotka sitä kautta on saanut kuluja pois.
Mutta ku se kohdistuu semmoiseen väestön osaan,
joka on sitten aina kuluttanut tilistään,
sai se enempi taikka vähemmän, ni se on pistänyt kaikki rahansa kulutuksen.
Köisi, minusta voi alkaa lamaan tuntua olla tässä,
että pikkisen kansanratioon katta niinko sitä ynnäpäätä lisättyi.
Miteikäs, mitenkäs tämä maali vaan nyt pyörikään.
Ei mulla oikeasta tätä, häntää muuta.
Ei muutako heimon alaa.
Nimeeni ei ole tärkeä, mutta asia on.
Mitä helvettiä tämä on?
Tämmönen asia, että meidän nautoja lähetetään tonne Keski-Eurooppaan ja Puolaan.
Mitä tämä on?
Mä oon niin vihanen, niin vihanen, ku olla ja osaa.
Yle teki hirvei nottia, noi tekee hirvei hyvää työtä.
Minä eläinrakkaana, eläinrakkaana ihmisenä, niin korvia särkee ja sydäntä särkee, ja en voi hyväksyä. Kiitos.
Ennen kuin kuullaan muutamat vinkit ja ehdotukset, niin Lahdesta käsin tullut meille viesti ihan kaikille, sekä päättäjille, että siviileille.
Mikäli päättäjillä on yhtään jäljellä moraalia tai vastuuta tekemistään päätöksistä, niin alkoholin kotiin kuljetus ei mene läpi.
Toki ihmisten itsekin tulee kasvaa vastuunkantoon ja vastuun ottoon, kasvetaan kaikki yhdessä, toinen toistamme tukien, ettei elämä mene ihan överiksi, terveiset lahest.
Kansan radion soititte.
Hyvää, iltapäivää.
Mistä päin pakkas Suomea soitat?
Tuota, Juazar, soitteli, ja tota, minnu ärryttää, kaikkein eniten tuo, uutistoimituksessa, näe nyt, tota, ni uutisia kun luvetta.
Oi joku uutinen, ja luvetta on pätkä siitä, että, ja sitten sanot, että, lukeeko loput netistä?
Niiest.
Ei kuule, kaikilla on nettiä, ja minulle ei ainakaan tule, koska minne sitä ymmärrä, kuitenka.
On tietysti joita harvoja tapauksia vanhuksissakin, joilla on netti, ja olkoot hyö siitä onnellisia, että oma on heillä.
Et tämmönen uutisen puolittaminen ja pätkiminen minua ärryttää kaikkea eniten.
Ja tota, minä toivoisen tämän radion tämmöset, millä on uutisia todella niinku, niinku ennenaika oli se STT-uutiset ja nää tämmöset.
Minnekä ne on kadonnu, sitä minä ihmettelen.
Ja kehittää, kylläpäs, radio-asema semmoinen, millä voisi kuunnellaan näitä entisajan ohjelmia niinku.
Ihan siis, vaikka nauhoitettuna, niit on kivaa kuunnella, niitä entisiä, entisiä juttuja, mitä on ollut radiossa, minun lapsuudessa ja nuoruvessa.
Nii just.
Ei millään kiitos muuta tälläkertaa ollutta.
Kiitos.
Tottakai. Hyvät päiväjatkot. Moi.
Kiit, moi.
Haluaisin, kyllä nyt antaa vinkin meiä Suomen puolustusvoimille, ku väki ostaa näitä ohjuksia ja Pitkämartan kantamaa aseita tuona itsellään käyttöön.
Ni miksi ei Suomi tee kauppaa, esim. Iraniaa, Eteläkorealassa. Norjaan osti vastikään Eteläkoreasta pikammatta ohjuksia, otetaan mekin ne käyttöön, tehdää yhteishankita, tulle edullisemmaks.
Ei, luulis olevan vaikeeta. Jotenka, herra Antti häkkänee, puolustusministeri. Tehkääpä nyt päätös, ottakaa kultainen kylä tätee, kirjattakaa sille, pätkä miehelle kirjastinee. Korjaa ja sanokaa, otan niitä, kymmenen tuotta kappahetta. Ei, maksa juuri mitä, merätenne hävittäjii.
No, ei, mulla on muutaku kivaa. Keväkökkelee kaikille. Morjes.
Hyvän tuotteen nimeä käytetään väärennöksiin, ja varsinkin, kun seuraavan kerran ostat kruuneperin torttua. Ni et sinä osta aitoa kruuneperin torttua, vaan sinä vaan ostat jonkun tortun, jolla on nimi kruuneperin torttu.
Tätä käytetään hävyttömästi, hyödyksi, saadakseen myyntituottoja kyseiselle tuotteelle, ja kun nyt luette sieltä niitä raaka-aineita, ja sitä määrää, EKD, ja lisäasioita, mitä sinne on laitettu, ni siitäkin voitte jo päätellä, että ei ole kysymys aidosta kruuneperin tortusta.
Ei varmasti 1800-luvulla ole käytetty palmuöljyjä, eikä näitä EKD-kymmeniä kappaleita.
Eli, jättäkääpä, kruuneperin tortut ostamatta, elleivät ne ole aitoja.
Eipä tässä muuta vuosihan joudutaan odottaa, heippa.
Kuuntelin kansanradiota, josta Roua ihmetteli sitä, että koiran kakit, ni jätetää vaan.
Runsaat parikymmentä vuotta sitten kävin Espanjassa, Barcelonassa, hyvin siisti kaupunki.
Ja tulin sit ääneen ihmetelleeks, et, mitä, et, eiks tääl oo yhtää koiria?
Ni, ku on, missään koiran kakkaa?
Ni, opas sitten sanoi, et, siellä ihmiset niinku pitää toisiaan kurissa.
Et, siellä ei nii vaan jätetäkään sitä koiran kakkaa.
Tulin sit kertoneeks siitä, tänne Suomen päästöessäni, ni, herälle, ja hän sanoi, et, ku hänellä on koira, ni hänellä haa aina niitä pussuja mukana.
Sit hän oli huomannu, et, siellä oli toinen Roua, joka oli sitten vaan kakittanu sen koiraansa, ja lähtenyt paikalta.
Hän oli sit mennyt tän Roua luo, ja sanonut, et, mulla on kyl ylimääränen pussi, et, jos sun pussi on, on jääny kotiin, et, mä annan tän sulle.
Siis oli tullu kaikkien aikojen haukut.
Eni, tässähän se ongelma nyt oi Suomessa, et, tääl sit, jos joku yrittää jotain sanoa toiselle, ni sit vaan haukutaan pystyyn.
Ja, ehkä nykyään ollaan jopa väkivaltaisiakin.
Et, joku semmonen yhteisprojekti voisi olla ihan hyvä, että aina vaan kimppuu, jos joku meinaa jättää, ja etelä eurooppalainen meininki,
että, vähän enemmän kiäntä, sitten, et, jos joku lähtee sieltä, koira kakit, ni jätetää, ni, et, tää monen viesti. Moi moi.
Joukko, painostus, ja kovaan ääneen yhdessä buuaaminen, ehkä me sillä tavalla sitten ehkäisemme koiran kakkavälinpitämättömyyttä.
Vaan sitten kynää ja paperia esiin on numeroa ja osoitetta luvassa.
Meidän WhatsApp-numerose on 044, 55, 154, 64, siihen vaan viestiä sekä äänitse, että tekstitse.
Perinteistä postia, jos haluaa lähettää, niin osoite on Kansan Radio, PL 79 000 24, Yleisradio.
Sähköpostiosoite meille on kansan.radio@yle.fi, ja se vastaaja 0800, 154, 64, ihmis vastaa, ja se odottaa, heti lähetyksen jälkeen suunnuntaisin, kolmen tunnin ajan.
Lasse Olkinoar sanoo ison kiitoksen kuuntelusta, ja isosti kiitän myös, jos osallistuit.
Kiitoksia tosin vähän erilaisia on luvassa myös tähän loppuun.
Ei muuta kuin päivän jatkot ja kevään odottelua.
Täällä yks penkki ajattelija, että eihän se niin huonosti mennyt, tämä olympialaiset, kun Suomi sai mitalin jääkiekko porukalle.
Sehän on aika iso kasa. Kapteelin, kun Amerika sai kultamitalit, ja sen jälkeen nousi lipput.
Siel oli Usan lippu, Kanadan lippu, ja meidän pienen Suomen lippu. Ilotaan siitä, minkälainen iso porukka tulee sitten Suomeen käymään, ja on mitalit mukana. Kiitoksia.
Täällä on Karimo. Tuota, minä, ku mulla on yks ainoa hyvä elämä tapa, ja se on pitkä kestoinen, kevykliikuntani.
Nyt kyllä haluisin kiittää noita Stara.
Katuhoito porukoita, et kyllä kävelytiet on ollut. En muista, et millonkaan ois ollut talvella näin hyvä kuin toisia.
Tietysti, sää, tietysti, käsattui tällaiset pitkät pakkaskaudet. Uskoisin, että liukastumisonnettomuuksia on vähemmän tapahtunu jalankuikiolle kävyelle liikenteelle, kuin aikaisempina vuosina.
Joo, moi.
No niin, no, Henke.
Mä oon jotenki kyllästynyt siihen, ku kaikki aina valittaa, valittaa. Kaikki o aina ongelmalista, ongelmalista.
Ei toivott, ei oo terveydenhuolto hyvää, eikä oo mitkään palvellut ei Suomest toimi. Kaikki aina natisee.
Kuka antaa niistä positiivista palautetta? Ei ketään. Aina negatiivist palautetta vaan pitää antaa niinku.
Mut pitäis antaa joskus positiivist palautetta julki. Mulla on ainakin positiivista palautetta paljonkin.
Mitä mun äiti on käynyt syöpähoidossa, ja kaikki. Sai kolmen kuukautta elinaikaa. Se oli vuonna 2019.
Ni, kuusi vuotta sen jälkeen se vieläkin porskuttaa täällä, et kyllä niitä asioita hoidetaan. Ei aina pidä natista ja valittaa. Olkaa joskus tyytyväisiä siihen, mitä meillä on.
Hän halusi vaan antaa tämmösen vertaipalantoisen positiivist palautteen.